donc je sais c'est on va avoir le
chapiteau tu vas être installés pendant
le tout festival tout l'événement
chapiteau prendra pas si c'est avec des
spectacles à l'intérieur de l'autre côté
on aura un foot rock et de ce côté ci on
va avoir un village associatif la maison
de l'étudiant centre névralgique du
festival les insensés sont au départ un
projet étudiant en master on s'appuyait
sur une proposition du code skis dans la
vie à la culture qui avait été fait en
2015 qui proposait de créer un événement
fédérateur fort sur saint quentin en
yvelines et nous on a voulu aussi
aujourd'hui pouvoir créer une dynamique
des servantes rennes dynamique
collective avec les associations locales
les associations étudiantes mes
partenaires institutionnels la
communauté d'agglomération les communes
autour trois jours de festival où se
mêleront parade bal populaire et
ateliers participatifs
parmi les partenaires les blacks blancs
beurs déclic théâtre et le théâtre du
sable la campagne a un petit chapiteau
qu'elle met à disposition pour le
festival voilà donc un pêcher plutôt en
gradins qui permet d'avoir un lieu
deuxième lieu de spectacle par à côté de
la maison de l'étudiant
la participation à la parade bien
entendu avec l'association vivre debout
et et b3 qui était un vrai travail qui
se créent en ce moment qui s'appelle
prises en compte
début des réjouissances vendredi 24 mars
à 20h